[Music]
hey what's up party people welcome to
honest trailer commentaries the show
where we will be giving you all of our
deepest darkest thoughts about shanghai
and the legend of the ten rings
shark thoughts oh deep and dark guitar
we'll show you uh uh some deleted scenes
uh we'll answer your questions and
comments if you haven't and we will
tease you with next week's honest
trailer uh which i am in the middle of
but i will take my mind back to shanghi
and tell you uh how i felt about it
overall which was i liked it um i was
entertained um i was entertained i liked
uh i i guess i'm an easy mark for for
martial arts films um i thought the
martial arts were uh competent to good
throughout um
i think that the movie probably should
have been about the dad
it was that part was way better and more
interesting and they spent like a good
hour of time in the in prologue and
backstory uh and just going diving more
and more into his character but overall
i thought this was like a agreeable uh
marvel experience if um forgetting
scorsese with it you know it was a theme
park ride but uh i'd i'd buy the
fastpass i enjoyed it i enjoyed my time
on it viper's a theme park right now
lifer's okay viper gives me like neck
problems
that's like
batman begins not batman begins that i
do like that batman roller coaster
smooth
we're talking six flags magic mountain
rides folks uh i personally think viper
like the greatest roller coaster i'll
just pause just but just briefly to to
talk about six flags magic mountain is i
went there maybe like two or three years
ago and got stuck on two different rides
that's the real magic mountain
experience i got stuck on goliath and i
got stuck on um
uh the one like is it tatsu where you're
like face down yes yes and and when
you're stuck there i'm just looking down
at like i guess where other people had
been stuck because there's like the
ghost of puke past sure like that people
had clearly been stuck hanging there
before because there's just like shadow
piles on the ground i feel like i've
been stuck on like every six flags ride
at least once
and this is like not um to be part of
stereotyping against uh young people and
teenagers but like i never want my life
to be in the hands of someone with
braces but it was many times
yeah a lot of times they had the braces
like aircraft arms returned a miracle
for sure
and then you'd just be off and then it
broke and i thought that kid's not going
to save my life it's yeah it's it's like
this incredibly dirty metal bar is all
that stands between you and oblivion
like all day at six flags so he's like i
don't wanna touch this bar but my life
depends upon it i love this this is like
an anti-branded spot for six months
honestly i like like
it was my favorite growing up yeah i
used to really enjoy going there as a
teen yeah
anyways
what do you think
um i really i really like this one uh my
i have one big caveat which will which
i'm sure we'll get into during during
the honest trailer but but for the most
part it's rare that i'll come away from
a marvel movie and my favorite stuff was
the action they're all action films and
they often have pretty good actor at
least one or two big scenes but that's
the kind of stuff that i'm sort of tired
of now like i feel like a lot of the
action beats are kind of samey and now i
kind of like the marvel movies for like
their individual little personality or
the aesthetic stuff that filmmakers
bring to it but in this case the
action's great like there's a lot of
really cool fights and i you know like
they're definitely blending traditional
martial arts and fight scenes with the
marvel sort of fantasy special effects
look and i i saw that a lot of critics
like didn't like that but i thought it
worked really great especially during
the climax like this has arguably the
best third act climactic payoff of maybe
any marvel movie no you mean the the
father-son fight right or are you
incredible i just mean the whole like
cutting back and forth between what's
basically like a marvel version of a
kaiju fight and then yeah the father-son
kung fu face-off i just think that whole
sequence works really well and it's it's
just it feels different enough from the
like we gotta stop this airship you go
blow up the engine and i'll go kill the
bad guy like it just like
i think we talked about this with black
widow where like that third act climax
had a real samey kind of like
feel that it's a lot like a lot of the
marvel movie endings and this one felt
really different and like really look
like it did bring in a little bit of the
woosha stuff and the martial arts kind
of hong kong stuff and depending on the
scene yeah blend it right and blend it
in with the marvel stuff to make it feel
like yeah you know yeah i dug it and you
know the characters were um uh fleshed
out enough uh again i think that dad was
the most interesting um by far and
hopefully i like the uh sister a lot too
menger jang is yeah the actress i'm i'm
blanking
gelling i think um yeah so we'll see
more of her and yeah maybe they can
gather the dragon balls and bring the
dad back
i like her throughout obviously she's
got that post-credit scene that's really
fun where it sort of sets up the ten
rings is like what they're gonna be in
the mcu movie i know yeah what's going
on there though like it just it
literally looks like a new coat of paint
like oh now we're
like graffiti the walls and now there's
skateboarding and so it's cool now and
so it's fun i love like the if like the
mafia did that
it got a little bit of like uh uh it's
like where the hackers hang out now like
it got kind of a 90s underground
sort of aesthetic upgrade yeah they just
need some
segments of chain link fences and tv
monitors yeah
um okay let's uh let's dive into
shanghai in the legend of ten rings
um and we'll we'll stop and start as we
go
[Music]
disney gave cap and tony chinese cell
phones replaced a tibetan hero with
tilda swinton and thanked prison camp
bureaucrats at the end of mulan but now
the magic kingdom will pander to the
middle kingdom by making a pretty
kick-ass martial arts movie okay it's
better than that time they dropped a
full episode of er shanghaine iron man 3
[Music]
paper
yeah i mean they do stuff like that all
the time like that is uh michael bay is
a big uh proponent of of the motherland
and uh they put this whole thing and
even in china that wasn't well received
uh at least by like fans on whatever
social network they have there right uh
but you
that was one of the biggest movies of
all time box office wise and
in no small part due to china
and i wonder why did shanxi ever get
released in china or were they just like
i don't think so i think i don't believe
it then but i don't believe it ever did
yeah
but no that's that's gotta sting
um and yeah i hope it was uh worth it to
make that joke uh when i disappeared
we don't follow the rules that all the
celebrities like the rock knows when the
movie comes out you got to be like and
do my friends in beijing like you got to
really yeah
we did not play by those i hope that one
day successful enough to record uh
apology video uh in mandarin like john
cena for that yeah
has never come to us and like look you
guys really need to apologize for what
you said about taipei like that's never
happened yet but maybe one day god
willing we will all be successful enough
one day to uh um to backtrack every joke
we've ever made about um about china and
that's all charity by the way parody
parody
i think i think the meg is one of the
few that really tried to do it in kind
of an elegant way where it doesn't just
feel like hey we got to go to shanghai
for reasons it's just like they needed a
beach the way and so it's like
china's got those like let's just use
one of those like it feels more organic
than almost any other move like so many
american films that have that very
specific beat where they're like well
you'll have to go and hit him but he's
in
the city of cheongdoo
i just hope that there's an equivalent
in china where they're making films that
like randomly take place in baltimore
like shall we go to the ravens game
like oh we could only get that
ingredient in houston
[Laughter]
for the very first time the mcu is
bringing a martial arts master from the
comics to the screen
yep the very first time the iron fist
sorry can't hear you as audiences
finally get to know shanghai a guy whose
most relatable quality is that he's also
getting to know chongqi who are you your
mother knew who she was do you who the
hell are you i'm not
pause for a second uh lon you you were
um not complaining but you were in your
notes you you thought simulu like wasn't
doing a good job in this role and i
disagree i thought he teased yeah i
teased this before like to me he's kind
of the the weak like it just feels like
it's kind of uh like physically in terms
of the fights he pulls it off it's great
like he like we we bring up iron fist
there like it's night and day compared
to finn jones like he looks very
believable doing the fighting and at no
point was i like it didn't look like he
did his homework or he absolutely fills
that part of the role
just performance-wise it felt kind of it
felt kind of flat it felt like i
couldn't usually with marvel characters
it almost goes the other way like the
problem is it's so on the nose about
like here's who this character is and
this is what defines them and it's just
like they're all like types and tropes
kind of and this i almost felt like i
don't have any sense for who shanghi is
other than the chosen one like i get
what his power set is but like who what
does he want or who is he what defines
him it's just like i don't know he likes
hanging out he likes everything he's
hanging out he's kind of defined by what
he's not you know he doesn't want to be
like his dad and he doesn't really you
know he doesn't feel like in touch with
his roots and he doesn't want to have
responsibility and you know but like but
what does he do
i mean i think that's something that's
answered over the course of the film um
but i think that you know he he has the
demeanor of somebody who was like a
trained killer from birth who then like
ran away and is trying to cover that up
and trying to keep who they really are
you know pushed down i thought that
i bought it and i and maybe it's
bleeding over uh because i like simulu
so much um outside of uh his roles like
he seems like such a funny nice guy i
thought you were going for like you're a
kim's convenience uh i like kim's
convenience yeah that's what i mean like
you would think a guy and i've seen
gibbs convenience and he pulls that off
like you would think a guy coming in
from a sitcom
would be such a natural fit for this
world i was really surprised that this
was my take well i like i i wonder where
he's gonna fit um
you know quip wise in with the uh the
other mcu characters like is are they
going to give him jokes or is he going
to be in like the
cap uh black panther you know react to
jokes i kind of feel like he's got the
like exactly what they do with aquafina
in this one where he's got a lot of like
i can say a matter-of-fact thing about
my franchise that's true and other
characters would be like all right water
dragon boy you know like he's got a lot
of mythology that he other characters
can tee off on you know okay
yeah like well not all of us have the
ten magic bracelets all right we gotta
you know like it's it's
it sort of writes itself kinda we'll see
um
oh we will oh we will we will see
keep playing
just like spider-man he's a parker with
a secret identity because underneath his
obligatory ass
beats the heart of a martial arts master
martial arts expert
martial arts enthusiast but nothing will
come between this one punch manchild and
the ultimate power fantasy no not
joining the avengers kicking your
father's ass edifice punch
the mcu's greatest threat has returned
bad dads tony long shines as the most
seamless example yet of digitally
de-aged actors what do you mean he still
looks like that wow not bad
he is maybe a time of this video release
60 years old it's crazy that is insane
it's bonkers and he's i assume that's
really him fighting in
a lot of the shots that's not all cg and
shot like there where he does like a
very impressive like jumping attack
that's really him because there's a
behind the scenes clip of him doing it
yeah so
incredible doing some of it yeah
ridiculous and also
that i mean i think this might also be
part of my issue with the main
performance is that he's so good and he
can do so much with with so lit he's
such an amazingly subtle actor like he
could do it it's all in like the eyes
and the face like he doesn't really even
need dialogue for a lot of this stuff
and uh yeah i did there were i totally
agree with what you say like there were
definitely times where i was like
i want to i want to follow this guy sir
like this he's on the trajectory that's
much more sort of dramatic i i i almost
wish they had figured out how to thread
that needle and just make them make a
mandarin just uh no it's not really the
chunking express but uh
with fireballs yeah exactly like in the
mood for glove and it's in the mood for
club about the infinity gauntlet yeah oh
man um
too many good ideas uh okay keep playing
neal
who still doesn't know the difference
between rings and bracelets who gave up
all his puzzles just briefly
is a real thing for you i understand i
understand that they uh um it's more
they had a cool idea like what if the
rings were like used to like whip people
and like you could beat them up with
that and stuff right
maybe they thought that the rings would
be too similar to the infinity gems or
whatever but why do they think that
maybe why do they call them rings very
clearly
uh well there are rings in the comics
like they are actual what you wear on
your finger i mean i guess like
technically the term ring doesn't only
mean a ring that a human being wears on
his finger like it could just be a
circle of metal as a ring
yeah
like tony lung called them um you know
ten rings and nobody was gonna like
challenge him
what are you gonna do he's the boss i
believe they are bracelets like nobody
wants to be that actually yeah that that
guy got pounded into the sand yeah a
thousand years ago
yeah right like the very first time he
brought them down the mountain and was
like look at these rings i found there
was like one guy it was like those
aren't
got smote immediately
um okay keep playing
in addition to his ten magic bracelets
he also commands the ten rings a secret
group like hydra or shield or sword or
the scrolls or the hand or the eternals
but what sets them apart from marvel's
other illuminatis and presumably
marvel's illuminati is that the ten
rings provide exciting new opportunities
in the world of evil franchising he
appropriated the ten rings my tan rings
up a ten rings in a country near you
we're more than just an evil franchise
we're an evil family twenty percent cash
damage required
i mean again i would have uh i know uh
beating a dead horse here but it would
have been so cool to have like a film
about his was it a 1 000 or 10 000 years
i think a thousand years right you keep
messing this up i thought it was a
thousand but dune now has me all
paranoid getting my thousand-year
errors wrong yeah and maybe even a more
natural way to work in some other mcu
stuff to see the ten rings you know
conquer the world and like go up against
wakanda or like uh madrapore or kamitage
i'm gonna just close this out there i
think a lot of these franchises are
under thinking their evil organizations
because we also this year had the arish
kage whatever yeah the evil ninja clan
from gi joe and or no they're not evil
they're but that's what i mean like well
yeah what do they do like i don't i i
really wish i had a better handle on the
ten rings overall goal they're they're
they're sort of cobra-esque where it's
like they're funding and pulling off
individual acts of terror around the
world yeah it's kind of like this i
thought it was just general organized
crime because out of nowhere when the
mom dies it's like 10 you know bootleg
yakuza show up and they're like yeah you
owe us money or like yeah but like
triads they run a gambling house but
there's that whole thing about like
disrupting governments and
assassinations and so like you feel like
there's a political goal behind it but
we never we never like get into what
that what they really want they always
just want like power and to have their
like mountain hideout thing and like
ninja training the really the end goal
seems to be
the ninja training and all the other
stuff just supports the ninja training i
mean why not if you can't have a room
full of people doing martial arts um uh
behind a closed door then what's the
point of power if you really should just
we should figure out how much do you
need just for the ninja school forget
you don't need the organized crime can
we just get some some investment some
venture capital going for this mountain
ninja school i'm sure the ceo of like
bird scooters you know has like uh
you like
tweak a handle on a special scooter and
then it flips around and there's just a
bunch of people um imagine being a jump
kick imagine being an american
billionaire with your own
ninja mountain ninja school in china
like what a flex like elon you want to
come we can go on the helicopter and do
the landing and they'll all greet us
with the swords like
who wouldn't want that jeff bezos would
sign up for that today immediately
yeah
uh okay
presumably the inspiration for ancient
chinese legends ancient middle earth
legends
and legendary pokemon for a film that
blends the action comedy of a jackie
chan flick with a high-flying combat of
wusha and the cgi toilet slurry of a
marvel third act
because while an emotional expertly
choreographed martial arts showdown
between father and son is cool isn't it
way cooler when a bunch of weightless
polygons smash into each other
no then why does it keep happening
yeah so you like you like the dragon
finish i didn't really agree with your
with your take on on that but you know
like i feel like the finale at least
like switched the order because the
emotional climax is him his father dying
uh and like passing on the rings right
and the duel that they have before that
and like okay i feel like it's it's done
and there's like nope nope dragon time
you gotta kill the the the kaiju though
you do but then kill the kaiju and then
kill your father i think that's the
those
you learn one thing from this movie it's
like
pemdas for
[Laughter]
the other thing that was really cool and
this obviously this is just like
the movie this is sort of everything but
uh it was a it was the rare third act
where it felt like a real surprise like
none of the trailers were like there's
gonna be dragons fighting at the end of
this like it really felt like they held
that in their pocket until you saw the
movie and you're like oh there's a whole
world behind this doorway that we really
didn't know about it does
it does suffer a little bit from that
there are shots where it's just like
well this is obviously some actors in a
green room in burbank and then this has
all been painted behind them like tallow
does have a little bit of that
impossible backdrop yeah you know where
you get that green screen kind of effect
but uh you know that's a that's a that's
a minor
yeah they all have that they do uh
except the eternals uh it's true she
could could have just been better or
worse
yeah okay let's keep going that's that's
another week
sean won't have to fight alone he's
joined by his sister jean ling who
learned to fight just by auditing
classes at murder university trevor
slatterly who pissed nerds off so much
in iron man 3 that his only friend is a
psychic chicken made out of butts
where's his face
psychic by chicken
and aquafina who pulls off four classic
marvel rolls at the same time platonic
love interest reaction face giver
the that just happened sidekick a guy
with a freaking machete foreign arm just
chopped our butts in half shawn used the
ten rings to like do this like crazy
kamehameha fireball that exploded the
thing that dragon everything vomited a
magical water map
and now i have no idea what's real
upgrade
um there were differing opinions on on
staff danielle who who couldn't be here
today was really not feeling uh aquafina
i i liked it i liked her um
again maybe it's just hold over goodwill
from other projects but uh i could tell
the movie kept making excuses for her to
be there but i did but i was glad that
they did
yeah long at one point makes a very
peculiar executive decision to where
she's just like she's in she's she's
part she's your lives are gonna change
yeah she's just like osmosis part of the
avengers now and it's like she doesn't
do anything you learned to shoot arrows
for about an hour like yeah she tried
literally an hour in archery is that all
it takes at this point like we're only
in phase four that's like more of a
phase 10 move yeah it's just like
anybody who could shoot you're in
yeah like i don't i mean i you know i
get it that they they want them to be
this kind of package deal and they
introduced aquafina to the world and now
they want to hang onto her like i get it
and i i liked the character too i had no
like you get who that's gonna be and
what her role is in the movie in the
first three seconds but i did appreciate
them getting her involved more in the
the action climax and you know like
she's a if anybody can pull it off
aquafina's fine uh
but yeah like it just feels really
random that they've decided she gets to
be a superhero now just because she's
like hanging out she took an archery
class and she's just like well i'll come
with you to china and then i guess be a
superhero now forever didn't they make
oh no that was for the sister um because
they like the mom
left two perfectly crafted
martial arts armors for
two adults just knowing that they would
come back at around that age and build
yeah one day you know
keep those dragon scale armors in the in
the vault yeah i'm gonna assume like my
son he stays in shape like he's gonna do
enough push-ups they're like i'll make
it this big but one day one day they'll
want to wear they're like one size fit
all someone said there's magic involved
yeah the dragons guys might be like like
the back to the future two coat where
just like you can sense how big you are
she knew she knew um but she didn't tell
her uh husband like by the way
you know i know we've been married and
like i've told you about my homeland but
i didn't tell you about uh you know that
portal that keeps like whispering to
people that's that's a lie there's not a
it may
you may hear voices coming from that
portal it's not me it's a dragon it's
just so you know it's just i mean we're
husband and wife i can tell you that
it's a cthulhu it's just we keep a
cthulhu
the cthulhu just don't let him out he's
going to say you're going to hear some
stuff
he's going to say all kinds of things
just ignore him yeah
he just wants to take care of our kids
please
don't uh immediately become evil if i
die just like you know try not to
keep going so for a franchise whose
roots are an openly racist money grab
enjoy a film that does its part to smash
those stereotypes except the one about
asian dudes being the biggest sneaker
heads in this solid martial arts fantasy
flick full of fun characters that
refreshingly stands on its own without
resorting to crossovers and team ups
until after the credits of course i
don't match any artifacts from our codex
they're not vibranium not like any alien
tech i've seen this could have been an
email
sorry honestly they could have just
shown those people they
give you absolutely nothing in that
scene they just gathered to say i don't
know you know
intergalactic zoom to be like i got i
don't know i got it i got nothing you
would never have a meeting about that
you would only have a meeting if you
discovered something and it was
complicated enough that you couldn't
just explain it in an email right
wong would send out uh you know the
specs and they'd be like sorry no clue
uh nope nothing no idea but yeah
there would have been like okay well
what time because imagine how hard it is
to coordinate timing with somebody who's
in space you're like all right you want
to say like three o'clock on tuesday
like wait i have what planet what
there's no [ __ ] tuesday i'm in deep
space it's
this you'll recall was also i had this
huge problem with infinity war and end
game and everybody said i was being oh
and thanos
it's been a week since i've seen you
it's like there's no [ __ ] week
instead there's gotta be a galactic
standard week in in space otherwise
you'll have a week yeah a nova week
yeah right you'd have to add a week
where where are we with zandar we
talking zandar one's end are weak that
that'd be that'd be ridiculous
[Laughter]
unrealistic yeah consistent timing in
space
that's not happening all right let's
finish up
destiny's child soldier
ring pop
house of flying swagger the human
calendar we've been friends for 10 years
okay you know i'm not an idiot i've been
by your side for half your life your dad
trained you to be an assassin when you
were seven he sent you on a hit
at 14. can you punch with all the colors
of the wind
deputy dog
i'm sorry your name is it's razorfist
ant-man
render the last dragon your soul is mine
a normal day on the sf metro
and how marvel casts its male heroes
love that guy
i'll take your shirt off
once upon a time in a china adjacent
pocket dimension
hmm so shanxi works with cars he's not
proud of who he used to be and he has a
difficult relationship with his dad
something about that backstory seems
convenient
yes thank you uh thank you to joe starr
who um i hope he's credited on this one
we need to add his name if he's not ryan
uh because he sent in like basically a
full script for chongqi like just he
just flew off the top ropes because you
can't keep joe away
away from martial arts you know he's
just he's always
always ready to
jump at the dojo um is he a black belt
yet wait can we get a joe star belt
check um
and then another good afternoon pre-tape
idea i want to say
it is i believe he i believe he does
have that at least that first degree
yeah i would hope he can all be seventh
degree black belts like uh our former
president but that's true that's true
i like i like what's an honorary seventh
degree black belt that's not a [ __ ] i
didn't know you could get an honorary
[ __ ] you see that the former president
trump received an honorary seventh
degree black belt in taekwondo this week
that's true look it up that's true
that's something
i'm not making now i remember and this
is not to um
you know besmirch the the good name of
of taekwondo um but uh when i had a
sleepover uh birthday party in about
seventh grade uh we had a kid who was a
a black belt in taekwondo and a kid who
was on the wrestling team and like in a
kind of preview of what ufc would come
to teach us is we made them fight each
other right
and
the black belt uh friend of ours got
absolutely smoked by the wrestler uh
time after time he just you can't get
the kicks off when someone's trying to
tackle you uh at least not not when
you're 13 14 years old yeah i mean i
guess that like that kind of like mma
thai boxing like that's that's the
specific thing they're working on there
it's like how do you integrate these so
that if a guy comes at you with a
wrestling move you can still get your
kicks in or at least in my experience
watching it you can get your like quick
punches to the back of their head it
seems like that's what it nine times out
of ten that's what those fights come
down to i'd love them to introduce a ufc
character into the mcu and he's just
like all the fights are just them just
like
driving around grappling just crap
waiting for it to finish like yeah
they're going they're really going at it
just like in the middle of this huge
battle those two are just like it's like
pulling each other's elbows
it's a lot of like rolling side to side
of
good times not the most cinematic uh but
effective um okay like just cast ken
shamrock just ken shamrock joins the mcu
yeah there you go
uh all right let's uh let's watch some
deleted scenes if we got them
starring
let me see that
that shang
the shogun of san francisco
simu-hang kim's resistance
shawn of the fled dragon ball t
busta rhymes karaoke these hands the
ringer
the big boss
kung fu hustler thinks tyler durden was
the hero fight club haha
that just happened aquafina is nora with
chi
if you like it then you got to take the
rings of it the breakdance fighting so
hot right now strangest things this dude
has a heck of a vega story iron fist and
bith
finfo fume dragon zord kung fulu
the lord of the rings
the prodigal son
the last dragon
chongqi and the legend of what are
clearly 10 bracelets
ranger fizz may seem like kind of a one
no villain but just look at his playlist
are we sure he didn't get blipped in the
90s yeah pause on that you can see
black hole son tommy the cat from primus
uh offspring sublime but i mean this is
k rock this is just k rock in uh in
1996. yeah i feel like they they
definitely just went to a spotify like
alt hits
playlist and uh and fold some fold some
titles yeah
uh good times that was uh that was that
was a fun movie to watch and talk about
uh yeah i enjoyed that one yeah i think
that uh marvel's in good hands uh until
uh until we do the eternals and um we'll
see we'll see what happens next we
haven't watched that one i can't believe
it i can't believe i've made it this far
not yet
for a real treat will the turtles be
well like okay
before hawkeye's over never mind
eternal comes out like
on digital i think like like
in like a month unfortunately we got we
gotta wait a while so uh
we'll percolate on that for a moment um
so let's go to fan questions uh renee
jimenez asks i felt the whole third act
was lacking the vision the fights and
the first part had way too flat
everything happened uh on the close-up
plane instead of wide shots well i i
agree that like the you know the martial
arts
scenes were the best part of the film to
me the bus fight fight on that uh
fight club and in and out of the fight
club and uh uh those things i liked
better than the big cgi battles at the
end but i think that they happened
almost too wide instead of too close up
like every screen is filled with like
every inch of the screen's filled with a
different you know little dragon and a
little two different cgi armies shooting
arrows and stuff like it was just
overload whereas the one-on-one martial
arts fighting really really did it for
me
i think both i thought all the action
was was pretty good in this one i have
to say
uh
bruinsfan1144s how would you like other
villains like trevor to return what
movie or show should sam rockwell return
should makey rorke's bird make a cameo
in a future movie or disney plus series
slash get their own disney plus series
um of the quest for his bird with sam
rockwell if they just do a road trip
movie with those two looking for the
bird um i think they're
he's dead right whiplash
in the universe is dead yeah whiplash is
dead justin hammer could fear my guess
would be
like they're they're doing that armor
wars series with yes they'll both be in
that which is going to be in the sort of
world of tony stark and iron man and i
would if if you're going to bring him
back that would be the obvious place to
do it uh i would i would not be
surprised if we got a rockwell reprise
there yeah they'll probably both show up
in that but i hope they get like their
own end game level like time travel
thing where they're going through the
multiverse uh visiting other mcu movies
looking for the bird
they've definitely done so much in the
mcu with like so many villains are
driven by their particular hatred of
tony stark yeah that you could do like a
team up like everybody who hates tony
stark gets together to just get revenge
on i guess he's already dead but like
he's stopped by industry go back in time
and make him yeah go back in time to
kill him twice more painfully this time
yeah
uh evan j pretzel comes in with the uh
speaking of six flags and the crazy man
who ate there every day could you do
that or would you go insane there was
somebody who took advantage of like uh
you buy some special ticket i think this
was decades ago and you can eat there
for free right if you have the yearly
pass you get like two free meals two
friends worked close enough and he timed
it out that he got like all his free
meals from
six flags
i don't know yeah um i don't know what
the options are
totally i know the funnel cake i would
probably get sick of in like a week
it's not really like a like not that the
food is so great at disney parks either
folks but like there's they they're big
on variety like if you're in
adventureland you've got these options
and if you're in yeah star wars land
you've got no it's all
churros yeah six flags is very much like
oh you want a terrible slice of pizza or
a terrible cheeseburger there
they do have um again something i would
probably get bored of pretty quick but
they have the giant turkey leg which i
think like four times a year is like
perfect to get that giant trick like
speak english thanksgiving this week um
i'm going to grab that leg see the giant
what evan's referring to was recently
because i read it yeah i write about
this more recently too yeah and he said
like because i remember the person
talking like they have a little bit more
variety now but it's still mostly you
know like not great
how did the giant turkey leg become a
renaissance fair food considering that
they did not have turkeys in europe but
they had like pheasants and you know
large foul that they would hunt
i guess i guess this is interesting our
what we are the first medieval food you
think of is giant turkey it's like no
they didn't have those in some type of
hundreds england suspend your disbelief
yeah
1144 also uh coming in with um uh the
implication is that they were rings for
a bigger beast like a dragon oh no
that's actually ryan in the chat ryan
you gotta mark your own your way
hang on yeah that's just my teacher yeah
that's just right
the dragon's wearing rings on its
fingers you've never seen a dragon do
that i think or because now that we
assume it's alien i think the idea is
that maybe it's a on a on a bigger beast
they would be rings
a 15 foot tall alien wearing these is
right i'll mark mine as ignore in this
show i didn't ignore it that's the thing
you just got to say from ryan
i'm just picturing like a dragon with
like bling like exactly like like
wearing a bunch of jewelry just like
what's up that'd be awesome um all right
and from we'll end with this from aj uh
what other superhero can feature in
shanghi's next adventure like hulk and
ragnarok or tony and homecoming who
would you would you pair shang with for
the next one
i mean it definitely like it does make
sense to take to team him with other
like magic kind of characters because
we're in a it's like a mystical kind of
world of magic but i do kind of also
like the idea because it is a little bit
i mean
obviously very powerful and we haven't
even seen all the things he could do
with the ten rings but they are also
he has kind of a street level
vibe like he's fighting like triads in
some scenes or whatever so like it could
be fun to team in with somebody like a
hawkeye who's a little bit more or like
a even like a black widow type or elaine
i mean it'd be perfect to like bring in
a daredevil
right yes like i mean like that kind of
a vibe so he could do like martial arts
type scenes against people who are only
armed with their fists as opposed to
epic yeah i would want him to be the
more powerful member of the team up
because i think if like captain marvel's
flying around just like head-butting
spaceships and he's like anybody with
captain marvel like maybe wanda could
keep up but anybody else is just like
yeah
it's very um you ever see that mitchell
and web sketch uh angel summoner in the
bmx band right yeah
i could ride my bmx across the roof how
about i just summon a horde of angels
so good
everybody watch that instead uh and then
go watch um
uh next week's uh episode that's uh
been a long time coming and it'll be an
even longer time watching um that's your
clue that's a clue for next week uh i
hope you had fun here in australia
commentaries uh no sju tomorrow oh i'm
just finding that out now we will be
reviewing hawkeye with eric instead
that's fun um and uh yeah so we will see
y'all then and uh and have a happy safe
thanksgiving or um if you're the rest of
the world thursday
see you later bye
[Music]
you